GABE WEISS: Hey, everyone.
Welcome to the Google Intel
webinar on the IoT platform.
We're going to start the
webinar here in a second.
And while it's running,
if you have any questions,
just ask them into
the live chat,
and we'll get to
them when it's done.
In the meantime,
enjoy the webinar.
Hey, everyone.
Thank you for tuning
into our first show
in a three-part series.
I'm Gabe Weiss, and
I work for Google
as a developer advocate
for the Cloud Platform.
MARTIN KRONBERG: Hi.
And I'm Martin
Kronberg from Intel.
I'm a technical
evangelist working
with our Internet of
Things technologies
and integrating them with
cloud partners such as Google.
So you know, I've been working
on creating proof of concepts
as well as a series of
workshops that we're
going to be teaching
in the near future,
and I'm really
excited to share what
I've learned with
a broader audience
through these webinars.
So today, we're going
to be discussing
how we can use Intel and
Google technologies to create
a predictive
maintenance framework.
Predictive maintenance
is a concept
of predicting when a component
in a factory or an airplane
is going to fail and then
replacing it before it does.
It's based around gathering
as much data as possible
from the system and then using
machine learning to, at first,
find anomalies in the data
and then predict anomalies
in that data before they happen.
In this first webinar, we're
going to look at the basics--
Intel and Google's place
in the IoT ecosystem,
gathering the sensor data,
and ingesting the sensor data
into Google's Cloud Platform.
So in order to build
out this framework,
we're going to be leveraging
Intel IoT hardware, Google's
Cloud IoT platform as well as
big data processing and machine
learning services
in the Google Cloud.
And hopefully, we can
inspire you guys to start
some of your own IoT projects.
GABE WEISS: So before we
launch into the specifics
of the framework,
let's take a minute
for a higher-level
overview of both Intel
and Google's place
in the IoT ecosystem.
So Martin, why don't
you start and give us
a rundown of what Intel
is doing in the IoT space?
MARTIN KRONBERG: Sure.
So, IoT starts with
endpoints, so things
like sensors, actuators,
the kinds of devices
that gather data and then
interface with the environment
in some way.
The simplest example
might be a thermometer
to read temperature
and then a relay
to turn on an HVAC system.
Now, at the other
end of the spectrum,
are the cloud-based analytics--
big data processing,
machine learning,
natural language processing.
And this is where a lot of the
really exciting possibilities
are like predictive maintenance.
But the thing about
machine learning
is that, while it has this
huge potential across almost
all industries, it's very
compute intensive, so much so
that doesn't really make
sense to run it locally
and we have to run
it in the cloud.
However, once we leverage
those cloud services,
that thermostat can all of
a sudden do more than just
tell you the
temperature right now.
It can begin to tell you the
temperature in the future using
predictive analytics.
GABE WEISS: And, of
course, all these things
need a way to talk to
that cloud service.
MARTIN KRONBERG: Right.
And so there's a
few issues that need
to be overcome in order
to make this happen.
First of all, many
endpoints do not
have a way to connect to
the internet on their own.
Now, they might have a serial
connection like USB, Modbus,
or maybe a short-range radio
like ZigBee, Z-Wave, Bluetooth.
And so this is where one of the
core aspects of the Intel IoT
ecosystem, or the
gateway, comes into play.
It acts like a data
collection hub.
It collects all the
data from the sensors
and then establishes a secure
connection to the cloud.
Now, having a central data
collection point like this
allows for a few other
things to happen.
First, even if we could connect
each one of these sensors
individually up to the cloud, it
would be inefficient as well as
insecure.
The connection
points that you have
in an IoT system, the larger the
potential cyberattack surface
becomes.
The gateway minimizes the
number of connections,
and it also comes
with some security
software that makes
that connection as
secure as possible.
GABE WEISS: So it
makes sense, when
you talk about these
gateways, are you
thinking of a specific device?
MARTIN KRONBERG: All right.
So there are a lot of
companies out there
that make these
gateway-type devices,
and they're going to range
in both performance, price,
size, as well as the kinds
of I/O that they have.
However, for this
webinar, we're going
to be focusing on the gateway
that comes with the Grove IoT
Developer Kit, and it
is an Atom-powered nook.
And this developer kit is
part of a larger developer
program at Intel.
Our developer program
is really aimed
at getting all of the tools
that IoT developers might need
as well as all the
information that they
need to use them in one place.
We have libraries, code
samples, even market studies
of different
verticals, as well as
community forums and all
kinds of training materials
like this very webinar.
And I would recommend that
anyone interested in learning
more about IoT development
go to software.intel.com/IoT
and check it out.
GABE WEISS: So to facilitate
these devices talking
to the cloud, Google has created
a new Google Cloud Platform
product, Cloud IoT Core.
It's aimed at communicating
with and managing
these fleets of devices.
It's not to say that it doesn't
work for individual tinkerers
as well, but the focus really is
at these large installations--
planet-scale, as we like to say.
Cloud IoT Core is a
fully-managed service,
so no need to spin anything up.
It just works and scales
and balances internally.
There's two pieces to it.
First is the Device
Manager, which
handles registering, tracking,
and configuring these devices
themselves.
Second is the communication
piece, which uses an MQTT
or HTTP bridge.
MARTIN KRONBERG: So GCP provides
an MQTT broker to send data to?
GABE WEISS: Right, although it's
not a fully-featured broker.
There's no configuration you can
do to the broker communication
part.
It just passes the payload
onto our messaging system,
Cloud Pub/Sub.
That's what we call a
bridge and not a broker.
So on the device
management side,
IoT Core organizes devices into
buckets we call registries.
Each registry maps one-to-one
to a particular Pub/Sub bucket
called a topic.
So any devices in
a given registry
will have all their messages
published to the associated
Pub/Sub topic.
There's not really enough
time in this webinar
to go into all the things you
can do with these devices,
but to touch on some of it, you
can pass configuration messages
back to the devices
from IoT Core.
You can enable or
disable a device,
assign properties to
individual devices,
or control the SSL key
expiration for security,
and more.
MARTIN KRONBERG: So then,
does GCP automatically
refresh the SSL
certificates that
are needed for the connection?
GABE WEISS: Not
automatically, no.
So best practice is, when
the device gets created,
you install a number
of certificates.
And then, in the
IoT Core interface,
you can specify timeouts
for individual certs
to do the rotation.
It's easier than having to
flash new services to the device
after it's already
installed somewhere,
possibly hard to get to.
So on that communication
side, messages
are handled simply with MQTT
being the dominant protocol.
Devices can send messages to
the IoT Core endpoint, which
then publishes their
payload to the next link
in the chain, Cloud Pub/Sub.
We'll talk in more
detail about what
you can do with these
messages once they hit
Pub/Sub in the next webinar.
The biggest takeaway
here is that Pub/Sub
subscales globally.
Each topic is available
from anywhere in the world
and can handle over a
million messages per second.
So you never have to
worry about your devices
overloading the system.
MARTIN KRONBERG: Wow.
That's a pretty
impressive bandwidth.
Is there a size limit to
the individual messages?
GABE WEISS: There is,
256k, which for devices
is a lot of sensor data.
But depending on the
device being used,
I'd never go that high.
Network usage is one of
the biggest drains on power
for these small devices.
That size is more
for the use case
of a device that would
sleep for a long time,
gather a bunch of data,
wake up, and deliver it
in the big burst, and then go
back to sleep for a long time.
MARTIN KRONBERG: Cool.
Well, let's take a
look at this framework.
So first we have a
few sensors here.
So we have a light sensor.
We have a sound sensor.
And we have a
temperature sensor.
These types of sensors
are used typically
in industrial
environments to monitor
machinery or various processes.
The sensors that we're
going to be using
are these Grove
prototyping sensors,
which are plugged into
an Arduino 101, which
we're using as a sensor hub.
These sensors are really
great for quickly prototyping
or creating a proof of concept.
They each have a socket,
which gives you power, ground,
and then two signal pins.
So there's no need
for breadboarding.
These sensors in particular
came from the IoT Developer Kit
which I mentioned earlier.
The Arduino 101 is connected
to our nook gateway via a USB.
We're going to be using the
Firmata protocol in order
to pass data between the
Arduino 101 and the gateway.
Essentially, Firmata virtualizes
the GPIOs on the Arduino,
allowing full control
from the gateway.
Now, on the gateway, we're going
to be using a Python script
to gather the sensor data,
package that data into JSON
objects, and then
connect to Google Cloud
to send data back and forth.
GABE WEISS: So how do you
interface with the sensors
on the gateway?
Are there libraries
that you're using?
MARTIN KRONBERG: Yeah.
So specifically, we're going
to be using MRAA and UPM.
MRAA is a low-level sensor
library created and maintained
by Intel for
interfacing with GPIOs,
I-squared-C buses, and SPIs.
Just to give you an idea
of how all this works,
here's a sample of
code that we're going
to be using in this project.
Basically, we're using MRAA
to connect to the Arduino
using the generic
Firmata protocol.
And then we're using UPM to
create three sensor objects,
sound, light, and temperature.
And then using
the sensor API dot
read or dot value to read
out the sensor values.
Pretty simple.
And what's really cool
about MRAA and UPM
is that these libraries
are 100% open source,
and they're compatible with
almost all developer platforms.
So you can run MRAA on
Raspberry Pi, BeagleBone,
all the Intel
gateway platforms--
UP Squared Board,
[? MidoBoard. ?] It even works
with some Altera FPGAs .
So once again, as
a developer, you're
going to have a
lot of flexibility.
You can start developing
on whatever platform you
have access to.
And then if you
decide that you need
to move over to
Intel architecture,
you can take your code as is--
for the most part--
and deploy it on a
different platform.
To be fair, there's going to
be some translation needed
from platform to platform.
For instance, not
all devices are
going to deploy USB to the
ttyACM0 node as a gateway has.
GABE WEISS: So once
the sensor data
is collected in
the gateway, then
we need to get it to the cloud.
This starts with the
devices implementing
that and MQTT protocol
to send messages.
MQTT stands for Message
Queue Telemetry Transport,
and it's a very lightweight
publish/subscribe protocol
that sits on top of TCP/IP.
It's ideal for the IoT world
because it's so efficient.
It works with the
low-power devices
without draining power too fast.
To talk over MQTT
to Cloud IoT Core,
developers need to use a
library in the language they're
using on the device.
There's good ones for
Python and Node.js.
There's also a C library
called Paho MQTT.
MARTIN KRONBERG: So there's
no need for any kind
of special GCP SDK or library?
Is there one even available?
GABE WEISS: Not for the
transmission of messages, no.
But the whole point
was we were aiming
at make it as easy as
possible for the devices.
So it's just this Google
endpoint for MQTT messages,
and that's it.
The manged service
then handles the rest.
Once we send the message
and the proper protocol,
that next piece is going
to be authentication.
IoT Core authenticates devices
using JWT, JSON Web Tokens.
I'm not going to go into
a lot of detail about it,
but we can include a link to
more information about it.
The tl-dr version is that it's
an encoded claim encrypted
with the public-private key
pair using either RSA or ECC
that's transmitted
as a JSON object.
Once you've got
that taken care of,
it's time to start
sending the data.
The message payloads can
be whatever you want.
Most of our examples use
JSON blobs of sensor data
because it's really easy
to pull JSON directly
into downstream pipelines
without too much extra work.
There's a few limitations
around the messages,
like that 256k size
that we mentioned.
Limits are listed clearly
in the docs, though.
On the cloud side,
to get all the setup,
you need to have
an account on GCP
with the Cloud IoT Core enabled.
And from there, you can create
your device registry, which
is tied to the Pub/Sub topic.
And once that
registry is created,
then you can register all
your devices with SSL keys.
And that's it to get your
basics up and running.
MARTIN KRONBERG: Well, it
sounds pretty straightforward.
Is there a place
where developers
can go to find a step-by-step
tutorial for starting
their own project?
GABE WEISS: Totally.
So if you go to Google
Cloud's website,
cloud.google.com, click
on the documentation
and there's a link to
everything right there.
MARTIN KRONBERG: All right.
Well, let's take a
look at some code
and figure out how all
this stuff actually works.
GABE WEISS: All right.
So for the code,
there's the two pieces
that I talked about before,
the JWT token creation
and the MQTT client
initialization.
So for the JWT token,
I'm highlighting here.
This is really all of the
code it is-- very tight.
So for JWTs, there's
three properties
that we're sending
for our tokens.
There's an initialization
time, an expiration time,
and then it's called
an audience key.
And the audience key is
how the receiver knows
what's being authenticated.
In our case, it's the
ID for the project
that we created in the
Google Cloud Platform.
I shows Intel webinar
as our project name.
MARTIN KRONBERG: Right.
GABE WEISS: Then
we can see here,
we're grabbing the
private key, which
lives on the device itself.
That's what was flashed
onto the device.
And that gets
encrypted with the JWT.
And then we encode it and
send it with, in our case,
we're using the RSA algorithm.
So that's it for JWT token.
The next piece is this
MQTT client initialization,
and that's this hunk
down here below.
And all it is, it's initialising
the MQTT client with an ID,
and that ID is this
super-long URL, which
is the ID for this individual
device in Google Cloud Platform
that we registered.
And then an MQTT
topic, which is how
the endpoint in
Google Cloud knows
where to send your
individual, what
bucket in Pub/Sub that its going
to end up identifying with.
So the device is associated
with the registry.
The registry is associated
with the Pub/Sub topic.
And that's how it knows
where to put that message.
From there, we established
our username/password.
And for our password,
it is that JWT
token that we created above.
And a couple of
callbacks, so we can just
track whats going on with the
client as it's doing its thing.
And then we set the TLS.
So the TLS is so that
the MQTT communication
is authenticated on both sides.
So the device is registered
with our SSL key.
That's how the Google side knows
the device is talking to it.
On the flip side,
the device needs
to be assured that it's
actually talking to Google.
For that we've retrieved a
root certificate from Google,
and that's how then
the device knows
it's talking to the cloud
service appropriately.
From there, this is
the MQTT endpoint
that Google has created,
MQTT.googleAPIs.com,
and that's how it knows where
to send the messages to.
And that's it for the
cloud communication.
MARTIN KRONBERG: Right.
And so then, once we establish
that cloud communication
to GCP, we're just going to
be creating a JSON object that
has, as you guys see, a
timestamp, the temperature,
the sound, and the light
values from our sensors.
And we're getting the
temperature, the sound,
and the light values
using those UPM libraries
that I mentioned earlier.
We're publishing this
to our MQTT topic,
and we're doing
this once a second--
basically, continuously until
we shut this script down.
And that's all that
you really need
in order to create
the connection
and then start
sending data to GCP.
GABE WEISS: So that's
it for the basics.
Thanks everyone for
joining us today
and learning about Intel
devices and starting
to connect to Google's Cloud
Platform with those devices.
Tune in to our next
webinar to learn
about how the
messages from Pub/Sub
can be fed into
Google's data pipeline
to be analyzed and queried.
MARTIN KRONBERG:
Thanks everyone,
and we'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYS]
DIPAN SHETH: Hey, everybody.
Welcome back to
the Google studios.
We're here live, and
I am Dipan Sheth.
I'm a Google executive.
And you know Gabe
from the webinar.
Gabe and I are here to answer
any questions you guys have.
I really appreciate you
adding all those comments
in the comments section.
And we have other ones that
we've also gathered from folks.
So we're going go ahead
start with some Q&A.
GABE WEISS: Sounds good.
DIPAN SHETH: So one
of the questions
was, I built a prototype
with an IoT device.
How can I share my ideas
with the GCP developers?
And I'd love to
get their opinions.
GABE WEISS: Mm hmm.
So the best way probably
is to reach out.
There's a contact us.
So if you are on your console
in GCP, the hamburger up
on the top left,
you drop it down,
there's a support item there.
And there's a link directly
to community support,
and that will reach out
to not just those of us
that Google for
the GCP developers,
but also our extended
network, the GBGs and just
the greater community.
So there will be a lot of good
feedback for your device there.
DIPAN SHETH: Great There's a
really handy console in there.
The other question is,
is the code showing now
available on GitHub?
GABE WEISS: Soon.
So it's not available
on GitHub yet.
I'm going to put it up on mine.
But there's code that's very
similar to it on the IoT Core
docs.
So if you go into
cloud.google.com and click
on the IoT Core,
there's a section
in there about MQTT
client samples.
And the sample that's
there has, essentially,
the code that we've
been showing here.
DIPAN SHETH: Amazing.
Amazing work you guys are doing.
How much does it cost is a
question that comes up often.
So it's actually free to start.
It's 250 megabytes.
It's free.
And then, from there, it's
a tiered pricing plan.
It's available
online, and you'll
be able to see the tiers online.
So once you log in, you
can also contact sales
where there is a
button down there
to ask any other
questions related to it.
GABE WEISS: So the biggie is
that, because it's serverless,
you're paying for what you use.
So you're basically paying
for network traffic only.
DIPAN SHETH: Yep.
You mentioned that IoT Core
supports both MQTT and HTTPS
in the video.
Which one should they use?
GABE WEISS: So it really
depends on your use case.
Broadly speaking, my gut take
on IoT in general, use MQTT.
HTTP sends a lot of extra stuff
along with the transmission--
all your headers
and all of that.
So since you're paying
for the amount of data
that you transmit,
HTTP in the long term
is going to cost you more.
And also, because you're
sending more data,
it's battery consumption.
The biggest killer
of these devices
is going to be network traffic.
So the more traffic
you send, the quicker
it's going to drain your
battery on these devices.
So MQTT is becoming, basically,
the de facto standard
in the industry, so
that's what we suggest.
DIPAN SHETH: Great.
Great.
So the other one is, what
kind of quality of service
do you support for
the MQTT protocol?
GABE WEISS: Right.
So there's three
different levels
of service for those that don't
know about quality of service.
There's no guarantee that
the message got sent,
so you just kind of fire
it off into the internet
and pray that it gets
to where it needs to go.
There's guaranteed
at least once,
and there's guaranteed
once and only once.
So the levels that we support
are that fire and forget,
level 0, and level 1,
which is at least once.
We don't support level 2, which
is the once and only once.
The performance hit
on it isn't scalable,
and it won't work
well with iOS devices.
DIPAN SHETH: Another
question that just popped up,
thank you for
asking the question.
Do you have setup
procedures for this?
GABE WEISS: As far as getting
started with this, no.
Because it's a
serverless setup, as long
as you've got your
GCP project set up,
you're basically good to go.
And that hamburger menu
down, all the way down there
is IoT Core listed.
And you should have
it in the console,
and you can just get
started right away creating
your registry, registering
your devices like we described,
and away you go.
You shouldn't have
to do anything more.
It should all
already be enabled.
DIPAN SHETH: There
might be a good plug.
There's also a
subsequent webinars
coming up to show you different
levels of the IoT Core
platform.
GABE WEISS: Right.
So in this webinar, we
covered the Intel hardware
devices and how to get
them talking to the GCP
in that initial IoT Core piece.
And then the next
webinar are coming up,
we're going to cover more
information about Pub/Sub,
our messaging system,
and into BigQuery,
which is going to be very cool.
And then the third
one coming up after
is going to be on
machine learning.
So stay tuned for our
next webinars coming up.
DIPAN SHETH: Great.
We appreciate the
comments and the feedback,
and we're glad it helped.
I think the last
question was very
similar to the other one is,
what do I need to get started?
And I think you just answered
that, so that's great.
GABE WEISS: All right.
DIPAN SHETH: Anything else?
GABE WEISS: I think that's it.
So like we said, stay tuned
for the next webinars.
Thank you everyone
for tuning into this,
and we'll see you next time.
DIPAN SHETH:
Appreciate your time.
Thanks.